head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts let's jump to
this next story from the post millennial
California moves to explore every legal
option to getp off the 2024 ballot by
December 28th guys okay Michael I'm
going on vacation right this this we
wrap Friday and then I'm gone we got to
get one week out of the year and they're
trying to make Trump kicked off the
ballot in during my vacation what am I'm
gonna do they knew you were leaving and
they're like this is our time but hold
on here's something that else say
interesting and there's something to
think about I don't think Gavin yum is
dumb I think he is strategic in many
ways they there's zero chance Trump wins
California so this is clearly them
building steps for the future because
he's not at all concerned Trump is going
to to be get California's but that's not
what it's about it's about 10 million
Republican votes in California that
count towards Trump's uh uh general
election and so what's going to happen
is Donald Trump will win the electoral
college with 50 million to Joe Biden or
whoever is 70 million then they will
then the Democrats will come out
screaming being like ladies and
gentlemen the man who is currently
giving the GI given the nuclear football
right does not represent this country
they say that now with the Senate of
course like oh like why it's not fair
that West Virginia has the same number
of Senators as California well it's
actually is fair they each have equal
numbers because they're States that's
why they did it that was the purp the
point the point as they know as they
know yep so I think you know what is I'm
sorry what's one more thing Tim the
thing about Free Speech free speech is
great if people are arguing in good
faith but and there's difference between
someone who's just a leftist as
Progressive views and there's lots of
people and there's many strong Arguments
for progressivism things like this that
are be done on political government
level are not being done in good faith
this is that's the difference this is
the bigger issue with getting Trump's
name off the ballot removing him from
the primaries on super Tuesday yeah they
don't think Trump will win a general
election they would strip him of popular
vote totals but more
importantly they removed Trump from the
ballot before the primary Nikki Haley is
the nominee but also they can dis way
just say any look if you're a member of
the NRA you're an insurrectionist you
can't run for office yeah it's just that
easy I look I just don't see
any future that doesn't
involve if it's not a civil war it's a
totalitarian revolution of some sort
it's a Bic Revolution I I I strongly
disagree that those the only two things
on the table I'm not saying only oh okay
sorry okay I'm I'm saying like there is
no return to normaly but here it was
never normal we were just brainwashed to
thinking was normal I understand that
but we had a period what I mean is for
for those of us between the ages of you
know let's just say 20 and 40 we had a
system that is gone and what what we are
going into will be 100 times more
extreme and more tumultuous than
anything we've experienced I agree with
that completely and that's a good thing
I think that's necessary I think you
need the enema to get rid of the poop
yeah could be a short-term relatively
short-term bout of chaos no I don't
think short-term well you got to Define
it could be 15 years that that's pretty
long term that would be short term in my
opinion well the Civil War is only four
yeah but I mean I'm talking like real
Global the American Revolution was 20 is
that long was 20 20 the American
revolutionary period was 20 years yeah
the uh well the period not the whole War
the the but but the but the War I I
think the idea of the Revolutionary War
is is less meaningful than the
revolutionary period like the Boston yes
that's fair the Boston Tea Party Like
Red Coats were killing people before
there was a war that's fair so we talk
about the war but the revolutionary
period was 20 years and um the uh what
is it the first battle of the
Revolutionary War took place a year and
a few months before the signing of the
Declaration of Independence it's funny
that a lot of people think the signing
of the Declaration started the the the
revolution It's like because they get
years later wait but they get it in
history textbook and I'm not going to
fault this where it's all stacked on top
of each other it's it's very hard to con
narrative the Nar makes sense that way
that's that's sort of true it history is
condensed but no I think the reality is
people just don't read history they hear
what do we know the holiday July 4th why
because in 1776 they signed the
Declaration of dependence do you know
what the actual date of the signing was
the the what the Declaration of
dependence no what second was it yeah
and then uh or it may have actually been
before that I believe it was the second
and then it took uh two days to get
everyone sign it I I don't I don't even
know no I think it was signed on the
second and then it was uh not in
circulation and publicly known until the
4th I could be wrong but something like
that if you read books you would think
that there's only two genders and no
scientist thinks this
anymore not the ones that are allowed to
practice sorry I just want to mess with
the chat room so but but but anyway back
to the uh back to what's going on with
California
let me ask you if uh Trump is removed
from these
ballots Nikki Haley there is there is I
I I don't think Trump getting Ro from
the ballots then it's just like well
we're just going to go ahead with the
election and it's it's whatever whoever
Plan B is for the Republicans that's not
how it works I think things are going to
get very very ugly very very quickly uh
I will be paying rosan in that
circumstance I think we might have I
don't know what it would we we got to
get into this but um you may have to pay
her you know we're going to talk about
that well we'll we we'll we'll get into
that for those for for those that aren't
familiar uh Roseanne said on this show
how long ago that was a few few months
ago March wow long time ago uh Roseanne
said wow I can't believe how long it's
been I think so yeah Roseanne said that
she didn't think there'd be an election
there were two bets we made that's right
military tribunals everyone everyone
remembers the second bet they're they're
all forgetting the first bet I think you
won the first one yeah no no no she
said what did she say she said there' be
Mass arrests by the end of the year yeah
that's not happening but hold on have a
couple week left right no no hold on she
said Trump would there would be M
military tribunals and I'm like you're
saying Trump will have people arrested
like or the Democrats are going to
arrest people I'll take either if either
case I'll give her $1,000 if the
Democrats have mass arrest she wins fine
that's true too in the next week okay
well that's not that's not zero% that's
not zero it's not zero no no no it's not
zero I'm not saying it's zero but anyway
uh someone also bet me that Trump and my
my buddy who's a failed podcaster Tom
Woods someone on Twitter bet me $500
that Trump would be reinstated in the
White House by January 1st 2024 not 2025
meaning they would overturn the 2020
election and have Trump in the White
House by 2024 now there's a non-zero
chance that'll happen next week but I'm
looking no that's that's zero right the
idea that Democrats would arrest people
they've already arrested Trump and
Trump's legal team and you know his
lawyers and other people involved so the
idea that the Democrats would stage Mass
arrests is like maybe like
05 that's fair but the idea that Trump
has reinstated is like okay fine it's in
it's in the realm of physical reality
but like we're talking
0.00000000 1% right it would be more
likely that like the Secretary of
Commerce becomes president like everyone
else gets knocked off yeah it'd be more
likely that the plot of designated
Survivor happens Line forl Line Reality
yeah exactly yes I just come on no I
like that show but it went off the rail
so quickly oh I don't know I didn't
watch it I just know the general premise
like everybody dies but him and they're
like your president he's like why it's
like Ral you're like 200th in line so
you're in charge here it's like well
you're here I guess that makes it you
and uh and here we go uh so so what do
you think you think that if California
actually makes the move as well well
they are making the move I know right
but I'm saying like but what are they
make what moves have they taken did
Gavin just call it or lieutenant
governor said Trump should be removed
for the same reason okay and she it was
really funny because she said you
everyone knows you have to be 40 years
old and cannot have staged an
Insurrection or whatever and everyone's
like neither of those are true like the
the fascinating thing about Colorado's
ruling Supreme Court of Colorado is that
the third uh article three of the 14th
Amendment actually does not include the
president and they even said it in their
ruling they said it's just self-evident
that's not how the law works you don't
get to be like well the law doesn't say
we can arrest you but we think they
intended that it's pretty obvious right
you're under arrest the law is what ever
those in power decide liws yes as people
are learning Steve D is really good
about this he goes this has always been
I was shocked that someone who's a
conservative and not Anarchist could be
like this is a country of Will and not
laws and it always has been the
anarchist perspective yeah the idea that
Free Speech existed in this country at
any point is
laughable uh the the Sedition Act
president Adams were arresting
journalists for criticizing the
government first and and and not just
that we had obscenity laws George Carlin
got arrested for swearing yes so if you
want if you want to make arguments about
the limits of of free speech
it's it's been better than it's been in
a long time and it's not a function of
the Constitution which has not changed
it's been a function of the culture
which is always more important than any
piece of paper that's why we make you
know songs yes that's why we we make
skate videos that's why it's so
important what the daily wire is doing
and you know a lot of people I here will
say things like uh oh I want to get
involved in the fight so I'm going to do
a podcast and I'm like well I got to be
honest like we we probably got too many
of those you know some may be better
than others but what we need is music
video games and TV shows movies comedy
you know why it's important because
there has to be as little or no social
cost for opting out if you have
Alternatives where I can play video
games I like gamergate I just want to
play video games where I can play video
games and get action figures and get
laid and watch programs and not be
involved with their whole edifice then
we've won yeah that's the plan man I
think it's happening don't you think
it's happening more and more I agree I
agree I think with the major boycotts we
saw of this year we are with Disney's
failures do you you not think hold on
let me interrupt do you not think it's
hilarious I mean I that John fedman
handed over case of Bud Light to whoever
it was was that not funny well what do
you think about the Bud Light thing
right now what what's happening now well
so right now kid Rocka said it's over he
said we gave him a black eye it's what
they deserved I think we're good uh Joe
Rogan laughed said it was stupid and
then bought uh several cases of Bud
Light out and drank them with with some
comedians like Shane Gillis I think they
posted a photo of it and uh Dana White
says they're align with you more than
you realize and everyone who who
believes in this country should Goten by
Bud
Light
um the Matt Matt Walsh has come out and
said no the boycott is still on hold the
line
I don't understand the point of pulling
a boycott here's let's let's take
something out of this let's a little
unpolitical way do you have any siblings
Ian yeah two brother or sister two
brothers okay let's suppose I'm on a
podcast and I say an insulting thing
about your brother is a dumb joke and
you you come to me you go you you
shouldn't have said it hurt his feelings
and I felt bad about it and I'd be like
you know what that was screwed up I'm
sorry I would apologize to you I would
ask your brother for an apology and I'd
be like here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to keep his name out of my mouth
for the future because I don't want to
hurt his feeling he didn't deserve that
in that case you would accept my apology
because you you know what I made a
stupid joke I didn't mean it harm was
done and it was resolved maybe I'd give
them like a say hey buy beer on my
behalf right you have when you to
forgive someone they have to apologize
and acknowledge what they did wrong and
own it maybe let me give you another
scenario in my opinion uh do you have
any siblings yes uh a sister sister uh
is terrible okay so Ian Praises your
sister that's pry you got out there
pretty creative what have I done no no
no okay let's let's let's for real so so
you insult you know Ian's brother yeah
and Ian says hey you shouldn't have done
that that's that that was mean and you
shouldn't say it so you go okay give
your brother $100 on me and $100 to you
we'll be done with it should he say okay
or should he be like no I don't want
your money I want you I want your
apology I think it depends on our
relationship if he could tell I really
do feel bad also I'm giving you you just
go buy dinner on me then that's
different but if he no apology you just
say you you just privately say okay well
how about I give you a 100 bucks and we
we'll I would take that apology my
Integrity is not worth $100 I'd be like
keep your money and you don't have to
say anything about my brother but I know
who you are now and the apology
acknowledges that there was wrong done
yes that's the thing you have to be cash
is saying please stop talking about this
go away I'm paying here's my concern
right now let's ask Ian what he thinks
your brother outside of outside of the
the the brother analogy I understand
your point the concern I have with the
budlight thing is you've lost Joe Rogan
you've lost Kid Rock you've lost Dana
White uh and we have seen some political
gains I I don't really care about
platitudes so what have we seen $100
million goes to UFC you end up with
people like Sean Strickland coming out
saying uh yeah I'll I'll just tell you
what he said he said that trans people
should not they should not be accepted
by what what they're going through
should not be accepted by Society either
but my the point with he said a bunch of
things that like you can't say on
YouTube and he said sponsored by Bud
Light he also just tweeted that January
6 is the most patriotic thing that this
country has has done in a long time
that's better this is a guy who was
saying thank you budlight for sponsoring
my speech and allowing me to say this I
view that as on par with what they did
with Dylan mulani so it's sort of a moot
you know neutralizing force in a certain
degree but my bigger concern is if the
catalyzing forces of the boycott have
basically bowed out that means you've
lost a few generals sure what's going to
happen is come April the wraparound for
year-to-year profits is going to hit Bud
light's going to report earnings they're
going to see a net positive gain because
it's a year-over-year their their stock
is already recovered they're going to
declare victory over the boycott so what
I'm saying is either you join with the
likes of Joe Rogan and Kid Rock Dana
White and Sean Strickland and say hahaa
we've won declare victory over your
enemies but or if you do want to
maintain the boycott and double down you
need an advancing strategy how are you
going to get them to apologize uh I I
can't remember who was tweeting about
this at um who was tweeting about this
they said we we would need to see I
think it might have been James Lindsay
um test testimony before Congress as to
how this happened have a Republicans
call them in and say what was this that
caused damage to the shareholders
Victory and lawsuits but the idea that
we simply just don't do anything and
that's what a boycott is we don't buy
their product and we just it go on with
our lives I think is is is not an option
so there's been a divide in this many
people saying Hold the Line keep the
boycott up and I say okay what's the
next plan what's the next move because
if you do nothing they'll take back the
battlefield I I agree broadly speaking
but I'm just going to make one point I
know people are going to melt down I
don't think what budlight did is as bad
as some of these other companies are
doing like when you're talking okay it's
a trans influencer we made a like a
custom bottle can for for for D melany
great that's one thing well that wasn't
the issue hold on just one more thing
when you have things like Target with
like tucking panties for kids like
that's but Target so much harder for
people that also did not happen what
happened then please the talking was for
adults okay still the concern is that
they have all of this stuff front and
center and available for children they
had gender neutral swimwear yes talking
St was I apologize to Target that's a
bad example I'm saying is you still
don't have to apologize for them just
make sure I want to be clar I I want to
speak correctly so I don't want to be
like Target you know I'm glad that you
corrected me what I'm saying is there's
other organizations that do things that
are far more malevolent than take
someone who's already influencer and
make them like a oneoff thing I got to C
you on budlight it wasn't that dlan M
got can is that Dylan mvan was hired and
paid what is the report is $180,000 to
promote Bud Light and a contest they
were doing I'm just saying it's
important because the I'm saying it's
people think that you could go to
Walmart and get a Dylan malany can you
could not have done that it was a custom
can just for Dylan but that's not what
anyone's mad about the corporate press
claimed that was the the cause of the
boycott it was not the cause of the
boycott was that Dylan mulany grabbed a
stack of budlight put them on the table
and said everyone buy Bud Light and use
this hashtag to win a contest hashtag
whatever I don't March Madness or
something was paid According to some
some reports $180,000 and Del M's Del
mulan's audience is children so people
were like why are they promoting this
gender ideology stuff and why are they
promoting it to children children the
media then immediately ran out and said
budlight gave a custom can to one person
and the right lost their mind to
obfuscate and lie about what happened
Fair my point is there are many such
cases where they are targeting children
not via somebody but directly oh yeah
and like when you have these Publishers
who are publishing these books that are
pornographic content for kids they are
to me are much more malevolent than some
D and malany fig there's a big story
right now daily wire's tweeting about it
and Wess tweeted it it's a Coco melon is
that what it's called where it's an
interracial gay couple singing to their
son who's dancing in girls clothing and
so you know daily wire of course saying
this is why we made bent key we'll talk
about that in the members only show so
we can get more in depth because I do
want to I I do want to get back to the
politics can I say one more thing it's
also important in terms of boycotts
things like this to pick your battles
because it's much more useful to take
down someone who is both much more evil
and who you can win than someone where
it's just like you know like water for
ducks back my my view on Bud Light is
and I hate but I I don't understand
everyone drinks but light to begin with
May snob and like I'm not going to buy
it you know like when we we don't we
don't even buy sodas we buy the spin DS
cuz like 17 calories fruit juices I've
got my Dr Pepper zero that's disgusting
it's it's my primary method of hydration
not I'm not kidding at all my my PE is
jet black well thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net